[Music]
the movie begins with an intriguing
advertisement about men's appearance the
narrator says that some men have pretty
eyes nice shaped jaws and a slim figure
but they are not the ones we will be
focusing on for the moment the men
opposite of the aforementioned features
are the ones who need help this is when
we are introduced to a new invention
called the handsome suit it is a
bodysuit especially designed for obese
and ugly men to turn them attractive in
an instant it doesn't change their
appearance permanently but with a
handsome suit men who have been ugly
their whole life can take a taste of
what it's like to be on the other side
of the spectrum one such victim of his
appearance is the 33 year old takuro he
is an amazing cook who owns a restaurant
and has a great personality everyone
loves takuro as a friend but as soon as
he tries to approach a woman in a
romantic way he is reminded of his
weight his wide nose and his
non-existent jawline since his teenage
days he has been rejected by a total of
101 women not just that but 52 of those
women ran away crying and 25 reported
him to the police at least tekuro is
brave enough to speak to women takuro's
love life is nothing but a huge joke
which has affected his confidence
gravely and the root of all his problems
is that he is ugly because of this he is
the perfect candidate to be the brand
ambassador of the handsome suit one
afternoon takuro is working at his
restaurant as usual when a beautiful
girl named hiroko approaches him she is
interested in joining the restaurant as
a waitress without even looking at the
resume takuru hires her and is delighted
to have someone as pretty as her working
alongside him as days pass tokuro falls
deeper in love with hiroko whenever she
locks eyes with him and doesn't run away
he thinks she is expressing her love
when tokuro isn't around an elderly
staff member asks hiroko why she wanted
to work in the restaurant when there are
better opportunities for her here in the
city hiroko reveals that she came to the
restaurant a few months ago with her
father at that time a man was caught for
not paying the bill after eating but
instead of being mad at the guy takuro
asked him for his reasons and allowed
him to pay any time in the future his
kindness touched hiroko's heart which is
why she wanted to work in the restaurant
after listening to the story the elderly
man believes that takuru finally has a
shot with a woman somewhere else takuro
goes to his friends hise and toto and
asks them if he is ugly they do not
think before affirming that he is one of
the ugliest men they know however they
ask him to not let his ugliness be a
drawback and confess if he has feelings
for someone still in a dilemma takuro
goes to a children's park and stays
there for a long time then he is
approached by the salesman of the
handsome suit he proposes to kuro to be
a brand ambassador for the product but
takuro refuses to make a show of his
ugliness the next day during lunch
takuru makes hiroko his favorite dish
she is blown away by the taste and
expresses how much she loves it but a
naivetokuro thinks she is confessing her
love for him when she repeatedly says
that she is in love he replies that he
too is in love with her uh oh he waits
for her to run away in tears but she
takes him by surprise and inquires what
it is that he loves about her taken
aback takero manages to blurt that she
is perfect in every sense her eyes
earlobes her hair and even her pores are
perfect the answer makes hiroko believe
that he only loves her because of her
looks which is not the kind of love she
wants to receive from a man takuro has
lost all hope now that he has been
rejected 102 times the very next day he
goes to the handsome suit store and
meets the manager initially he is
skeptical because the suits look like
penguins he wants to leave but the
manager and the owner repeatedly tell
him that this will change his life
eventually takuro stops arguing and
agrees to test them out this is when
magic happens and takuro comes out as a
handsome lad with muscular arms and a
chiseled face he can see a jawline on
himself for the first time and is
stunned by it he continues trying on all
the other suits and changes into many
different handsome men after much
consideration he chooses the one he
likes best and buys it the manager also
tells him about the special sound button
on his throat that changes his voice
tokuro explores his options and chooses
the deepest and sexiest voice hi mystery
recapped here at last he names himself
hikariyama because it sounds more
attractive than his actual name before
leaving he is warned to stay away from
hot water while wearing the suit and to
keep the suit a secret in the very first
hour of being handsome takuro
experiences pretty privilege the woman
he used to shoot dirty looks at him in
the bus now smiles at him many teenage
girls fawn over him the waitress serves
him unlimited refills and the women in
the streets are nicer to him in general
takuro even bumps into a modeling
manager who wants him to model for his
company the next day takuro is in his
usual ugly form when a woman named moto
enters the restaurant she has come to
inquire about the job as a waitress
after hiroko left the position has been
vacant but the customers don't want moto
to replace someone as pretty as hiroko
takuro protests and hires her saying
that looks don't matter when it comes to
serving even moto is surprised because
she has never been treated with kindness
like takuro shows her over the next few
days she wins everyone's heart with her
hard work but like tekuro she is seen as
just friendly and not attractive when
takuro and moto are together she often
flirts with him but passes it off as a
joke takuro also begins to like her but
thinks it is purely platonic then a week
later he goes to the modeling agency and
meets the manager although it is his
first gig and he can hardly pose
everyone praises him no matter how bad
he is his face makes him a better model
than everyone else after the shoot he
meets a supermodel named rika she thinks
he is too silly to be in the industry
and fires him on the first day but
tekuro manages to win her over because
of his personality for the first time in
her life rika feels attracted to someone
she even invites him to dinner at her
house with her friends at night he goes
to her place and discovers that her
friends are none other than his best
friends he say and toto he pulls himself
together and impresses them with his
cooking skills now that he is handsome
his talents are praised more than usual
throughout the night tekuro slips out of
his mask many times first when his voice
changes and then when toto compares him
to his fatter self however he manages to
keep his secret hidden and return home
he is exhausted after pretending to be
someone else and wants to cook like
usual moto is also at the restaurant to
help him prepare for the next day she
has made a wrist warmer for him that
plays his favorite song it is silly but
tekuro appreciates the thoughtfulness
they talk about different things and
accidentally touch hands while doing so
it sparks a strange feeling in both of
their hearts they do not know what to
make of it and decide to just ignore it
instead in the following montage we see
tekuro taking part in several modeling
gigs he is in advertisements and on
billboards and is living his dream
everywhere he goes groups of women
follow him and he can finally pick and
choose a partner as time passes rika
starts falling in love with him because
of his persona but he is still attracted
to hiroko only when he is sure that he
has reached an admirable height of
success he finally goes to meet hiroko
as his handsome self he expresses his
feelings like in the movies but to
hiroko it seems like a stranger is
trying to hit on her she excuses herself
and walks away but takuro is so
delusional that he believes she is just
shy later that day moto and takuro go
out to shop for groceries on their way
back home moto notices that takuro is
not in a good mood to make him feel
better she suggests they play a game
where they have to take pictures of
happy people in the market at first
takuro thinks the idea is stupid but by
playing the game he realizes that
happiness comes from the small things in
life like narrating for you guys moto
also takes pictures of him enjoying ice
cream to show him how happy he looks
without takuro realizing he has begun to
like moto at night he cannot get her out
of his head and sleeps while looking at
the pictures they took in the market the
following day after the shoot kakuro is
alone with rika when she leans in to
kiss him although he isn't attracted to
her he doesn't want to miss a chance to
kiss a girl for the first time they make
out but tekuro imagines that he's
kissing moto that's
okay when things get heated he feels
uncomfortable and stops her to catch a
breath he says he wants to take a shower
before making love and goes to the
bathroom what tokuro forgets is that he
cannot wet the suit with hot water
because of this simple mistake the suit
peels off his body and he misses the
chance to make love to a supermodel he
sneaks out of the bathroom and runs away
before she can see him the next morning
they meet again at the studio and rika
is furious she has never had a man
reject her which makes her want him even
more to get out of the situation takuro
says that he wants to take their
relationship slow later the manager
reveals that takuro has been invited to
walk in the annual fashion show
organized by a popular brand the show
will open several gates of opportunity
for him hence it is crucial that he does
well after the discussion takuro is
informed that he will have to take a hot
shower for today's shoot he refuses to
do so and makes up an excuse everyone
believes him but a former model who is
jealous of tekuro's success suspects
that something is wrong at night
everyone is at a party organized for his
birthday takara signs a deal of 5
million dollars with the modeling
company just when he thinks that he
cannot be happier the jealous model
pours hot coffee on him fortunately for
takuro the lights go off at that instant
and he manages to run away without being
seen on his way back the suit comes off
and is completely damaged he directly
goes to the showroom and asks the
salesman for a new suit then he is
introduced to the permanent handsome
suit which will completely turn him into
a handsome model however it comes with a
price and he has to lose his former
identity all together he gives it some
thought and then decides to buy the suit
on the way back home he accidentally
bumps into a woman and is accused of
groping just because of his looks people
assume that he is a pervert he is even
taken to the police station and has to
be bailed out by his co-workers upon
returning home moto tells him that she
knows he must have been falsely accused
because he is not someone who could make
a woman feel uncomfortable takuro
finally gets ready to tell her the whole
truth but she dismisses him a while
later hiroko returns to the restaurant
and asks if she can talk to him for a
while they go to a park where she
reveals that she was overjoyed when he
first revealed that he loved her tekuro
thinks she is making fun of him and asks
her to go away her reappearance makes
all his effort to be a different person
fruitless in a fit of rage he wears the
permanent suit and decides to forget his
former life all together the next day is
the day of the fashion show it is the
biggest opportunity for takuro but all
he can think of is moto somewhere else
moto gets into an accident when a
motorbike hits her on the road when
tokuro is informed of this he is in
shock before he can react he is pushed
onto the stage but refuses to walk he
has finally realized that he doesn't
want this life he was the happiest when
he was with moto in the market he
ditches the show and runs to the back
room however he forgets that the suit he
is wearing is permanent as the last
attempt to return to his fatter self he
cuts his skin thankfully the plan works
and the manager gets to see him as he is
in the following scene takuro arrives at
the hospital and finds out the biker is
the one who is hurt and not moto he is
relieved to see her well they go to talk
in private where takuro is met with the
biggest surprise of his life moto opens
her fat suit and reveals she is actually
heroko she was tired of people liking
her because of her looks which is why
she wanted to test him she apologizes
for lying to him and the two finally get
together subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching